hier se terminer la saison de l'émission
mario premier regard diffusée sur m6 et
c'est des records d'audience
une arrière-garde jamais l'émission doit
aussi bien marché alors deux raisons à
cela je vous lis un le programme était
très bon cette année très beau casting
et u2 les autres chaînes dorment
oui je vous le dis c'est vrai les autres
tf1 ils prennent que des tournures des
semaines alors hier ça a été un petit
peu mieux et camping paradis mais avant
il y avait h 24 la série qui joue dans
un hôpital mais sur la tête de ma mère
ils l'ont fait dans une épicerie on
comprend rien même le lit on voit que
c'est par un lit d'hôpital
donc bon ça ça fait trois semaines de
quatre semaines tu prenais des tôles sur
france 2 bon bah comme d'habitude c'est
france 2 france 3 va comme d'habitude
c'est france 3 mais rasta rockett w9 a
cartonné encore une fois mais c'est vrai
que c'est grâce à ces deux raisons m6 a
cartonné et m6 a sorti son épingle du
jeu là comme tf1 france télé s'est vite
ce que nous aussi on dort en prin-times
on peut pas dire que ce soit la fête
voilà d'or et bien comme nous on dort et
m'a forcément m6 se réveille il cartonne
avec top chef et cartonne avec marie au
premier regard et c'est pas la peine
qu'on voit notre notre jeu c'est bon il
y avait des bons d'achat corse apprend à
marcher plus de 600 milles mais c'est
vrai qu'en prime time on va pas se
mentir c'est 8 on dort voilà donc à
france 3 ils dorment tout le temps
france 2 il donc tout le temps
voilà m6 donc syrte en épingle du jeu
tf1 c'est un mois catastrophiques pour
les prêteurs et les centristes auront
lieu tout toutes les séries américaines
de tf1 se plante donc forcément m6 et
marion les regards cartonné en pékin
express très bon démarrage et top chef
qui cartonne toutes les semaines top
chef puisque ils sont très souvent même
premier des audiences tout un
lotissement fondu donc m6 on peut pas
dire qu'ils fassent voilà ils ont ils
ont rien fait de spécial
ils ont gardé leur programme mais comme
les 29 ont des programmes ripoux et on
est les premiers à le faire aussi je
suis voilà on est je me mets dedans
assez vite on n'a fait que de la merde
et je leur ai écoutés et bien dès lors
deux chaînes dans le top 5 c'est pas mal
enfin bien sûr c'est w9 qui cartonne
tous les soirs aussi en pointe panne
alors y'a un couple qui a fait
énormément réagir non mariés au premier
regard c'est le couple adrien elodie
alors souvenez-vous nous avions reçu
adrien sur le plateau qui témoignait de
la froideur et de la difficulté qu'il a
eue pour conquérir mélodies
ce soir ces mélodies qui sort du silence
qu'elle a beaucoup de choses à nous dire
mélodique
elle affirme avoir été victime voilà
deux d'erreur de montage
voilà de montage pas biaiser la variété
pas en sa faveur et d'invention de
séquences de la part de la production
on va en parler vous allez nous dire ce
que vous en pensez alors si vous pensez
que melody dit vrai ou pas petite vidéo
récapitulative
et je vous le dis mélodie est très
attendue ce soir je le vois sur les
réseaux est c'est vrai qu'elle s'est
fait un petit peu bousculé sur les
réseaux et tous les gens l'attendent
attend des explications et mélodie est
avec nous juste après ça s'est pas
retiré cap hier soir sur m6 était
diffusé le dernier épisode de la
quatrième saison de mariée au premier
regard
dans ce bilan on a pu constater qu'entre
delphine et romain tout allait pour le
mieux un an après le tournage de
l'émission le couple semble toujours
aussi épanouie
regarde même bonheur partagé pour
joachim et elodie qui compte bien
renouveler leurs voeux
et oui nous sommes toujours mariés pour
tous les autres couples en revanche
c'est l'hécatombe séparation en douceur
ou avec fracas les tourtereaux de cette
saison 4 n'auront pas tenu la distance à
l'instar d'adrien et mélodies procès la
désillusion si on pensait qu adrien
était amoureux de mélodies c'est
finalement lui qui a décidé de se
séparer après avoir souhaité rester
mariée une première fois mais si cette
séparation est un coup dur pour mélodie
ça n'est pas le seul la jeune femme a
fait savoir qu'elle n'était pas du tout
contente du montage qui avait été fait
d'elle dans l'émission selon elle la
production de l'émission aurait beaucoup
modifier la réalité
je me rends compte que je ne sais pas si
c'est une vraie expérience j'ai
l'impression en tout cas pour ma part
que mon histoire à haute et très
scénarisé qu'ils ont voulu nous donner
une certaine image qu'ils avaient en
tête depuis le départ en dehors de son
portrait qu'elle trouve à charge la
jeune femme se plaint aussi d'une
séquence en particulier qui auraient été
truqués lors de son mariage avec adrien
dès les premiers pas de danse elle lui
demande d'arrêter
c'est une séquence inventé je ne lui ai
jamais demandé d'arrêter un montage
grossier sur lequel la productrice a
tenu à réagir
ce moment de gêne a eu lieu elle a dit
plusieurs fois arrête à adrien mélodie
un vrai souci avec le tactile
bien sûr tout est raconté plus
rapidement mais le fond reste la vérité
ce soir mais le diet avec nous en
plateau pour tout nous expliquer
[Applaudissements]
pas trop stressé un petit peu oui
il vous fait pas peur autour de la table
c'est peut-être qu'ils mais régulière à
jeu c'est bon vous savez moi c'est me
regarde et on s'y s'exhale commence à
s'y faire on ne gagne pas c'est normal
c'est comme ça alors bon sinon on va
voir votre portrait puisque dans votre
portrait l'émission vous décrit comme
étant intransigeante et très dur avec
vos partenaires
j'ai toujours été très dur j'ai toujours
été exigeant tout d'accord avec mes
partenaires effectivement avec vous il
ya beaucoup de choses c'est beaucoup
d'histoires d'amour j'ai eu deux longues
relations et à chaque fois c'est vrai
que mélodie c'est une tannée qua non à
dire tous ses jeux ses rangs que je
m'ouvre en fait d'accord et l'autre
n'apprivoise je m'ouvre et après non non
je suis comme ça heureusement sinon je
m'achète une corde et j'adore et une
fois que vous faites confiance après
fait partie et ben là c'est exactement
ses tartines c'est la paix 2010 j'ai 28
ans donc ça fait un an et demi que je
suis célibataire
j'ai eu deux relations dans ma vie mais
deux seuls et uniques relation je ne
peux pas me donner à quelqu'un juste
pour un soir et c'est tout lancar hyper
je peux faire fuir certains m et
aujourd'hui si je suis intransigeant et
dur aussi avec les hommes
c'est en grande partie par avoir une
relation que j'entretiens avec mon père
parce que j'ai toujours voulu me
surpasser lui montrer que je pouvais
[Applaudissements]
elodie je vous mets là où s'est tenue
avec adrien et non d'une célibataire
oui divorce est célibataire oui j'aurais
peut-être un truc à vous dire dans un
instant on n'attaque pas couleur d'ébène
cela ouais mais j'espère que vous avez
je pense que vous avez bien fait de
venir
est ce que le portrait était fidèle à ce
que vous êtes non pourquoi
le portrait n'est pas nuancé c'est à
dire ce qu'on veut aux fins qui est mis
en avant au travers du montage c'est pas
méchant
non non c'est pas des méchants du tout
c'est une personne exigeante et
intransigeante parce que je le suis
c'est vrai vous savez que parce qu'en
télé ils ont ils sont obligés de grossir
les traits forcément parce que pour que
les téléspectateurs et moi je suis le
premier téléspectateurs aussi je me dis
j'ai besoin de savoir
ah oui je me dis mélodies ah ouais c'est
la jeune fille qui est difficile qui est
intransigeante tout ça si on dit vous
êtes introduction que vous aimez les
glaces et vous aimez la vie on va
oublier
oui mais il ya plein de trait de
caractère qui seront tout aussi fort et
qui ne sont pas du tout au contraire le
corps un trait de caractère
alors ça se voit la prégnance lorient
excellente j'aime les échanges
relationnels je suis dynamique j'ai
beaucoup d'humour tout ça ça doit par va
vous re bien sûr qu'ils hébergent jean
michel bayle l'image qui a été plus
commentés de votre aventure c'est lors
du mariage
on voit qu'il y en a un des deux qui
étaient beaucoup plus chaud que l'autre
est beaucoup plus chaud pour bien sûr
aller plus loin adrien qui était très
sympa d il est très sympathique qui
l'avez vous êtes resté peu ou pas du
tout on a une relation cordiale eux lui
et moi projet d'accord c'est à dire
bonsoir iata non ni tél
un nantais est ravie quand je la vois
arriver je suis super enthousiaste parce
qu'il me plaît tout de suite je suis
resté le meilleur
au moment où je me retrouve face à lui
tu as été le gros coup de coeur adrien
ne correspond pas aux critères physiques
de mon futur mari
donc je suis dans un moment d'hésitation
tu ne te présente mon papa en forme avec
plaisir si on attend trop mais comparé
les présentations tout à l'heure avec
plaisir tiens si on va plus loin je
l'attendais pas celle là il la peine de
venir
mélodie est ce que ça a été le coup de
foudre pour adrien ou pas du tout non
pas du tout donc quand vous l'avez vu
vous êtes dit quoi que c'est pas mal
c'est pas mon délire eux je me suis dit
ne correspond pas à mes critères
physiques habituel par contre quand je
suis arrivé très très bonne ambiance je
vais tâcher senti que nos deux familles
c'était très très bien dans sa rue ouais
et en plus on a eu un petit musée abbal
lui et moi arié quand même avec lui bien
sûr oui donc mais qu'est-ce qui a fait
que vous auriez pas pu dire non la ddb
live et où c'était maintenant j'ai eu
alors on dirait que ça j'ai hésité
pendant 25 minutes de cette fois j'ai
hésité même pas 30 secondes est en fait
ce qui m'a fait hésiter c'est de me dire
attends mélodique 8 marie passer ça tu
vas te marier
c'est un engagement quand même le
mariage donc donc c'est ce qui m'a fait
hésiter puis tout de suite on a eu une
joute verbale lui et moi je me suis dit
on a un bon feeling d'accord alors
ensuite on a fait un petit un petit
pêle-mêle de votre aventure avec adrien
on voit que ce n'était pas vraiment
l'amour fou entre vous deux puisque vous
avez beaucoup
recalé adrien regard des photographes du
monde adrien de me tenir par là
j'estime très rigide très bloquée et ma
main je la mets où tu peux lui tenir la
main
ça commence bien
moi je
1 la scène morange et non
[Musique]
non
2-3 caresses dans le dos
à vienne que pour
un ep
[Musique]
c'est vraiment froide avec lui comme ça
parce que vous êtes c'est vrai que sur
les réseaux sociaux tout le monde a dit
c'est pas possible ce qu adrien c'est
vrai qu'on ne s'attache à lui parce qu'
il est tout mignon il est gentil et
c'est vrai qu'on se dit le pauvre il
arrête pas de se faire recaler ça nous
fait un peu de peine est ce que vous
étiez aussi dur avec lui mais pas du
tout sinon il serait pas resté jusqu'au
bout je pense
ouais alors justement il nous avait
envoyé une vidéo off de la soirée où
vous dansez avec adrienne vidéo qui n'a
jamais été diffusé et on observe que
finalement tout était plus cool entre
vous deux regarde ça sait jamais
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
parce que et c'est normal ça ne laisse
donc on prend franchement joli chèque
pas la pierre à la promotion il ya une
journée annuelle dit arrête mais c'est
pas abad rien qu'elle direct dans
l'émission film c'est donc à la jeune
fille qui filmait mon ami c'est ça et
donc dans l'émission c'est en fait ils
ont dit arrête on croit que ça adrien
goût dit ça exactement parce que je suis
de dos d'ailleurs où on voit ce que j'ai
compris donc voilà donc en fait voilà
ces cas alors je n'avais reçu adria qui
nous expliquait avoir beaucoup souffert
et pleurer notamment lors d'un dîner où
la vire au froid dit sur le fait qu'il
puisse s'acoquiner avec vous pendant la
nuit de noces donc il ya il n'y a jamais
rien eu il est des noms il ya eu 6 il ya
eu déjà se tendre où ils viennent en
ardèche
deux jours avant le bilan de l'année
sinon y'a pas eu de s'en prendre à part
merci
bisous bisous à bâle aussi n'ont même
pas été la même pas se bat pas non mais
pas contre des gestes tendres mais ça
c'est dans le contexte c'est vrai que ça
faisait qu à moi sourire face et non
bien sûr
mais attendez moi mais moi mais moi je
moi je on ne voit pas facilement
mais comme toujours c'est peut-être un
peu calme voire la nuit s'annonce y
avait des doutes là dessus
bah ouais bah voilà comment tu ne nous
imagine en chine on imagine pas je sais
pas vraiment ses enfants de me saoulé là
tu veux toujours tous ses abonnés bien
sûr est ce que tu vois tu je met les
formes et te préserver par rapport à
certaines choses d'accord tu te
présentes pas quoi par rapport au fait
que t'es dur
tu me fous mur sur mur fou surtout je
prends j'encaisse je dis rien c'est pas
vrai j'accepte deux premiers procès est
maintenant et je te comprends et si
c'est normal et c'est normal j'arrivais
à apprivoiser monfette fait chuter les
faux culs dalloz me dire à moi que je
suis pas s'en faire
je
et
vous avez besoin de nous
vous allez nous dire si vous comprenez
qu'on puisse vous accusé de lui avoir
fait du mal et vous il ya une séquence
qui a été inventé par m6 on va revenir
sur une séquence qui aurait été inventé
par m6
selon mélodie vous avez nous donner
votre avis et vous aussi chez vous allez
voir cette séquence est dans un instant
mélodies moi j'aurai quelque chose à
vous proposer
parce que j'ai l'impression que marié au
premier regard ça n'a peut-être pas
marché mais l'amour au premier regard
dans tpm p ça peut peut-être marcher je
t'aime maison en attendant pas de coupe
a germé vous allez faire mais nous
sommes avec mélodie mélodies de mariée
au premier regard comment ça va mélodies
tout se passe bien pour l'instant
parfaitement alors mélodie on a vu que
vous aviez dit que c'est vrai que m6
avait bidonné quelques séquences selon
vous vous dites qu'une 6 par exemple a
inventé une séquence où les revenir sur
la séquence c'est la séquence de la
vanille ça nous rejoignent et mario
premier regard le principe est simple
deux personnes ne se connaissent pas
elles sont compatibles
elle se marie et après elle voit par
exemple moi la mélodie ça n'a pas marché
au bout de combien de temps à moi un
mois au bout d'un mois vous avez ouais
moi je voulais continuer ouais ouais
c'est vrai alors et alors il a dit non
pas parce qu'il vous non c'est vrai ça
c'est qu'on a une week-end en ardèche
deux jours avant le bilan et lors de ce
week-end ya eu des rapprochements ou pas
non à bas débit c'est quoi les
rapprochant alors c'est quoi j'en passe
les manques rabbins imams et rabbins du
bon jean quand je conduis vial on s'est
fait la bise
c'est vrai quoi c'est quoi les
rapprochements des gestes tendres l'un
envers l'autre
dans le genre oui des papouilles ces
gens de choisir les papouilles d'accord
les papouilles et du cou
on s'était dit au téléphone juste après
le week-end en ardèche et on s'était dit
qu'on n'avait qu'une hâte c'est
poursuivre en dehors des caméras pour
apprendre à se découvrir
adam braz et on arrive devant les
experts je dis oui parce que j'avais
vraiment envie de continuer avec cet
auvergnat me exact d'accord on peut
parler en anglais bien sûr évoqué et non
et du coup donc j'ai dit oui et lui a
dit non il a dit non à la vacance
surprise à mon avis je vous dire
pourquoi il a dit non adrien est jolie
quand quand vous êtes devant une porte
et que vous n'avez pas la clé un moment
j'essayais une fois deux fois trois fois
de rentrer effet un moment vous rentrez
chez vous et les paupières de passer par
la fenêtre mais forcément là il sentait
que c'était moyen moi ça m'a presque à
la fin je voudrais ce ne serait pas à la
fin je m'ouvre est vous vous sentez vous
regrettez on trouve qu est ce que vous
regrettez de ne plus être avec adrian
vous vous dites façon c'était s'était
pas l'homme de ma vie non avec du recul
je n'ai pas de regrets en plus j'ai été
moi même il a été ce que je pense muet
mais aussi il a été très bienveillant
avec moi après c'est dommage qu'il n'ait
pas voulu aller plus loin contrairement
à ce qu'on s'était dit d'accord alors
plus rien de ces camps donc on va revoir
c'est la séquence de la valise on entend
la voix off dire par exemple que le
voyage de noce était un fiasco
on regarde et vous allez nous dire
pourquoi cette séquence a été inventée
selon qui malgré le cadre idyllique des
côtes siciliennes
le voyage de noces se termine de la pire
des manières et c'est dans une ambiance
glaciale à qu'adrien et mélodies rentrer
en france
retour de cette lune de miel qui a
tourné au fiasco adrien et mélodies sont
chacun rentrait de leur côté
[Applaudissements]
donc il ya eu leur part ou un petit peu
houleux j'avoue je vais pas le nier avec
toulouse le ensuite on a beaucoup
discuté parce que c'était notre grande
qualité avec adrien on arrivait beaucoup
un communiqué donc on a discuté tout
allait mieux on a repris l'avion
ensemble le soir on avait une soirée
avec d'autres participants
donc on n'était pas à repartir mauvais
termes lui et moi et ensuite il a eu la
découverte de mon univers il est venue
deux jours chez moi qu'on a pas vu à
l'écran
j'ai passé deux jours chez lui à valence
du coup et après il ya eu le bilan alors
le bilan justement coup de tonnerre
adria a pris la décision de demander le
divorce
il a craqué mon adrien et contre toute
attente c'est vous comme vous l'aviez
dit un instant qui étiez là plus blessé
moi je vous sens déjà émue pour voir ça
non ça va est ce que vous voulez que
j'appelle adrien j'ai son numéro
allez pourquoi pas ça la honte parce que
l'on voulait que je joue à des jeux je
vous dis on va voir la séquence et je
lui ai demandé s'il est sûr parce que
parfois on dit des choses qu'on y est on
pense des choses qu'on ne voit si on
regarde et c'est à dire six et huit mois
il ya huit mois mais bon on attend de
réfléchir vous savez fois moi aussi j'ai
fait des erreurs et adrien a peut-être
fait une erreur il s'en rend compte que
ce soit en vous voyant les peut-être en
couplant sur mon jeu mais bon on va lui
demander tu l apg son labeur ils ont
remis ça ne la reçois comme un gars mais
il est vrai qu'on n'a pas la drire
aujourd'hui
était pas capable de nous faire
confiance pour moi
m
il n'y a pas d'avenir possible je
souhaite divorcer
c'est comme ça est ce que vous l'avez
eue au téléphone dernièrement elle est
rien oui mais qu'est ce que vous dites
c'est mort je l'appelle alors il est
rappelé à dieu s'appelle adrien ans il a
refait sa vie on va gestion des rejets
de numéro deux et numéro de tél
ça sonne première sonnerie je rappelle
qu adrien joue pour se rabibocher
adrien c'est cyril hanouna mon chéri ça
va on est en direct est ce que tu nous
regardes adrien babeau mon chéri battu
voix bah écoute tu fais comme toute la
france
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je te dis y'a pas de secret je suis avec
une personne que tu connais yd il se
nourrit donnez moi mais donnez-moi un
lot donnez moi un dîner mois mais doni
adrien je te sens déjà très en forme ça
fait quand on aime ce sport
tu peux prendre castaldi avec quoi ils à
faire comme directeur
adrien déjà j'aimerais ça fait huit mois
que l' aventure s'est terminée
adrien déjà est ce que toi tu fais de la
muscu pour séduire une personne avec qui
tu es en bail et que tu as peut-être en
ligne de mire
ou bien tu es peut-être déjà avec une
personne ou bien peut-être tué 100
personnes tuées dans le désert et tu te
dis il vaut mieux que je me muscle car
peut-être que je vais devoir bien
entendu gravir ddd d'une noble forcément
quand on est dans le désert alors qu'est
ce que c'est alors discrète je veux dire
qu'il se compliquer ty ou bien tu es
libre tu as été compliqué d'accord on
est d'accord façon je veux dire tu as
beau fixe et les règles au final c'est
compliqué c'est pas de moi c'est le
dadjè
m
adrien mon chéri juste tu as eu beaucoup
beaucoup de demandes fatale beaucoup
beaucoup de succès à la suite de
l'émission pas voir une classe c'est
vrai que là tu est extrêmement demandés
et forcément c'est comme 118 218 quand
il ya beaucoup de demandes de
renseignements parfois on enseigne est
très compliqué alors je professionnels
est-ce que tu encore des sentiments pour
mélodie à temps parce que tout cela
quand tu peux répéter ce que tu dis
elodie je pense que c'est définitivement
terminé ses morts c'est dead est ce
qu'ils pensaient est ce que tu penses à
elle parfois
alors pourquoi toi tu connais bien
mélodie est ce que je pense qu'elles
pourraient être séduites par jean michel
maire qui a traqué pour l avais je dois
disparaît support oui jean michel a
craqué pour mélodie
tout lui apprennent qu'ils pensent quoi
il ne fera pas avec des mélodies ce
n'est pas tout de suite moi d'accord
très bien conscients qu'ils ont très
bien en tout cas toi de rien mais
l'odyssée de la page s'est tournée
d'accord très bien merci j'ai pris votre
requête en deux d'accord merci merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir fait appel à nos
adria je te fais des gros bisous et une
bonne mère qui commence fort
tam au numéro maintenant c'est bien sûr
et si tu as trop de demandes n'hésite
pas bien entendu contacté je ferai
suivre à jean michel henric un merci
mais si ça mon mari alors juste une
mélodie très très vite
est ce que jean-michel peut-on style est
ce que jean mi mais il faut apprendre à
le connaître
non mais déjà des annonces est
d'ailleurs physiquement déjà est-ce que
c'est oui ou est-ce que c'est non erik
samakh jean michel aulas dit pas mal de
gens me choque ça veut dire que c'est
bon c'est dans la joie me permettre mais
on a un magnéto allait lui a dit qu'il
fallait à discuter ça plus approfondie
entre le couple apprécie enfin voilà
donc mélodie vous allez faire
connaissance avec jean-michel on va
suivre tout ça et peut-être que vous
serez bientôt mariée au deuxième on
regarde
[Applaudissements]